è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi andiamo
avanti con cats mario duella differenza
dall'episodio scorso è semplicemente una
che adesso questo è con questo che un
antistress possa diciamo sfogarmi nei
momenti di rabbia quindi poche parole vi
dirò soltanto che questo lo rivedrete va
beh lo lascio qui nel frattempo diciamo
che non ho capito bene come superare
questa trappola ho capito che devo fare
qualcosa con sta roba qui che sarebbe
una tartaruga sì esatto
ho cliccato questo affare che di sicuro
mi serve a qualcosa ma non ho capito
cosa allora in azione da andiamoci so
che cazzo cliccato ok dovrei avercela
fatta raga sempre che non ci siano tre
tra pro che ci prova e vai
ok sembra aver funzionato effettivamente
però non sono sicuro che ci sia
no il cazzo bene ha funzionato ma sono
morto e continua a morire porca [ __ ]
ce la si può fare è ok perfetto va
perfetto allora siamo arrivati al
secondo livello miracolosamente direi di
proseguire ragal ora andiamo avanti
[Musica]
allora devo capire non dovrebbe essere
tanto difficile niente difficile invece
è difficile porca [ __ ] difficile devo
capire come cazzo si fa sto punto no
niente niente niente niente niente
allora devo capire stare calmo devo
stare calmo e capire come andare avanti
niente perché mi dimentico di andare a
destra cazzo allora raga devo aspettare
che arrivi coe pezzente di merda usarlo
come se la macchia tso non riesco
neanche a colpirlo non è complicata la
faccenda devo saltare addosso a quel
cazzo di fantasmino e arrivare
dall'altra parte ma non ci arrivo ma
cazzo c'è ma mi sa di sì così
impossibili
dovete rendervi conto dell'impossibilità
dei videogames perché questo gioco è
impossibile e ci ho messo una [ __ ]
ora fare questo punto e siamo all'inizio
cazzo raga io impazzisco questa roba no
vi giuro c'è ma perché esiste
ma cazzo allora andiamo avanti cerchiamo
di stark armi alla tanto so già che c'è
una trappola lo so
da qualche parte c'è allora c'è un
trampolino che non devo prendere perché
se non vado sulle spine ok allora vado
avanti è caduto un fantasmino non ho
capito bene che cosa ci devo fare con
sta roba
mi sa che doveva ucciderlo prima devo
base però che cazzo di figata perfetto
allora ragazzi siamo credo di aver
appena superato una trappola senza
rendermene conto ma andiamo avanti
diventa sempre più impossibile allora io
so già che quindi deve incazzare perché
non riesco a farlo andiamo avanti qua ci
sono delle punte che devo saltare non ce
la faccio non ce la faccio 6 perché
perché sei un pezzo di merda 66 saltare
cazzo sta diventando traumatico come
gioco voi lo posso garantire
ok allora possiamo andare qui sotto che
andiamo avanti perfetto che cazzo devo
fare che non mi ricordo più ad ora
andiamo avanti fantasmini via perfetto
vai di saltare normalmente ok allora ce
la possiamo fare la che dobbiamo andare
avanti non ho capito bene che cazzo devo
fare qui
ebbene forse devo tornare come si fanno
andare avanti il nostro punto
devo bene questo non l'ho capita cosa
cazzo dovrei fare qui spiega ok
cos'è quella roba allora devo tipo
allora come cazzo charlie quante ce ne
sono viste cose
ok ce n'erano due fantastico chi cazzo è
c'è ma devo fare un ponte una cosa del
genere
tra l'altro ho notato che una piastrella
ri sopra è spaccata se dovete spiegarmi
che cazzo devo fare
allora ragazzi prima che io capisco a
cosa fare qui ci vorrà un eternità
quindi faccio che tagliare perché se no
posso stare qui tutto il giorno
perché c'erano i super sayan dietro ma
se tipo io scavalco qui non c'è un cazzo
si è rotto il cazzo
ho rotto il soffitto ma edizione cosa
devo fare qua devo andare a poor's
andrea destro che è fantastico di
scavalco tutto che mai un bug c'è posso
andare avanti quanto cazzo voglio che
figo cioè la bandiera che culo vai vai
deve mai meno 101 raga ma cazzo io ci
muoio su sto gioco ci muoio muoio ci
sono molto meno 102 volte e va a finire
che ci muoio anch'io se non si non si
può
dobbiamo metterci un attimo dobbiamo
calmarci raga dobbiamo calmarci non ci
cambiamo non ci chiamiamo anche perché
se io continuo a guardare le cose senza
giocare e naturale che muoio cazzo sono
un idiota
allora andiamo avanti ebbene è il
partito prima è partito prima pensavo
partisse dopo è partito prima e continua
a cadere ma perché mi consigliate sta
roba
io ci perdo le speranze ci perdo
veramente le specie allora io vi dico
oggi state vedendo questo video per
fortuna per grazia di dio
le nuove serie che ho cominciato a parte
quelle horror ovviamente ancora non
avete visto sono più tranquille di
questo perché almeno non mi incazzo c'è
almeno quella che vedrete venerdì vi in
farete un mucchio di risate di sicuro e
vele fate senza che io mi incazzo non è
meglio per tutti e allora perché
continua giocherà sta merda porca
[ __ ] non lo capirò mai comunque va
niente niente niente
che culo che cura assurdo mi sono
salvato di brutto
allora andiamo avanti ok mi stava minimo
ammazzando ce la possiamo fare
ma porca [ __ ] sapete cosa facciamo
un'idea fantastica avrà dato che sto
gioco è fattibile ed è tutta colpa di
sto stronzo
adesso gioca lui mi sembra un'idea buona
è vero siamo tutti contenti cosette
calata l'autostima ti capisco brutto
stronzo
ok ragazzi sono devo riuscire a capire
allora c'è sta roba che è rotta però non
ho capito come allora forse devo
saltarci sopra
ok ce la possiamo fare la gara allora il
ponte è fatto
dammi la forza per stare calmo sono in
un campo tranquillo pieno di fiori
farfalle gattini tutto allegro tutto
allegro gattini gattini cattivi porca
[ __ ]
vai vai vai all e finalmente porca [ __ ]
dalla ce la possiamo fare
[Musica]
ok allora ragazzo l'abbiamo fatta devo
riuscire ad andare avanti perfetto
ebbene devo cazzola la li è già crollato
qualcosa devo presumo che io debba
andare al no ok calmi non è successo
niente
tra questi mi servono per sabato cazzo
non è possibile ma ci potete va in
credere voi ma non ci meno 142 meno 140
di almeno 143
ok ragazzi sono ci sono
[Musica]
ci sono no non ci credo non ci voglio
non ci voglio credere
non ci vuoi non ci voglio credere non ci
non ci posso credere
raga no basta io non basta non ci gioco
più non ci gioco più porca [ __ ] non
ci gioco più è impossibile non è come
allora che mario era diverso nel senso
che t'ha ok perfetto ce l'ho fatta meno
male
dicevo che mario era diverso nel senso
che comunque tu capivi cosa dovevi fare
anche se muori di un miliardo di volte
qui non si capisce un cazzo cioè non
puoi andare avanti da solo è impossibile
cioè baculo non posso fermarmi un
millimetro prima della bandiera e morire
non posso non ce la posso fare non
reggere gli mio selvaggia mi conoscete
che sono instabile di mio se gioca ste
robe è una cosa c'è porca [ __ ] non ha
senso mi fa innervosire cribbio che
minchia devi prenderlo quel cazzo di
cupa ce l'hai fatta con niente impedito
adesso questo cupolo occhio è bravo ci
hai fatta bravissimo ce la posso fare
no non ce la posso fare io diego
continua a dire ce la posso fare perché
lo dico dall'inizio ma poi non ce la
faccio
cazzo è impossibile allora facciamo così
facciamo così che è meglio per tutti
allora aspettiamo che lo stronzo di
merda arrivi ok
prendiamoci anche un caffè né fra danzi
faccio la pausa bevo ok grazie ad esso
che quello stronzo di merda pali pro a
usarlo come trampolino vai ce la posso
fare
ce la fa
non ci credo
[Musica]
non ci credo [ __ ] la vedi la
bandiera vedi la bandiera non la vedi
non la vedi perché non c'è più sai dov'è
finita la razza in fila talento sono
morto quasi 200 volte è mio zio mi
sembra natale cazzo sono riuscito ad
andare avanti
bene allora adesso ho la bandiera quindi
se muoio chi se ne fotte cioè riparto da
qui
beh allora si è chiuso che cazzo è
successo che cazzo è sta roba addio a
noi due brutto pezzo di me che cazzo
oddio ho capito no kat
ero convinto di ucciderlo ma mica sono
un genio
allora come cazzo fa ok perfetto
ritrovata subito devo scavalcarlo se ce
l'ho fatta
allora è stato sempre cioè una botta di
culo allucinante ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
regalare andiamo avanti c'è un sergente
fatto fantasma allora penso che ci debba
saltare di sopra ok perfetto
l'importante è prenderlo ok madonna che
culo o chi andrà andiamo avanti ce la
posso fare vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
se siamo arrivati alla bandiera
mi basta toccarla mi basta premere un
tasto basso già che non finirà come
penso
ok ci prova raga
ma cos'è cazzo è successo vai vai vai
vai device è ok c'è lo rifà non ho preso
la moneta ma non penso serva un cazzo
minino fa niente allora io la bandiera
non la devo prendere di sicuro perché se
non finisco di merda
devo capire da ci sarà qualcosa di
nascosto qui da voi che parte di sicuro
però non capisco
ok lo trovo che era che ho trovato la
prima è bene allora adesso non capire
devo saltarci sopra di sicuro devo
spaccare come cazzo ci arrivo lì sopra
ce ne sarà un'altra da qualche parte
ok perfetto che ci siamo ragazzi siamo
calmi vista emoziona allora la bandiera
con la devo saltare per forza ok ci
siamo c'è ma che cazzo c'è qui sotto mio
zio mi sto saltando tutto ok raga bene
ci siamo
devo riuscire ok allora cosa devo fare
qui non lo so allora innanzitutto
innanzitutto un cazzo
brutto stronzo dove cazzo ok ti ho preso
basta trappola e non voglio scherzi
ok ci siamo forse posso andare qui giu
non so a cazzo non è che adesso decolla
tipo che mario ok credo di avercela
fatta
non ci credo e devo andare avanti di qua
credo si che cazzo è un'altra bandiera
non ci arriverò mai cazzo che è perfetto
ci sono arrivato incredibile non ci
posso ma ho vinto veramente cazzo si non
ci credo ce l'ho fatta
raga livello 3 livello miracolo non ci
posso credere ho fatto un livello in un
episodio se non si credo cazzo alla
faccia tua stronzo non ci posso che
ancora siamo sotto che cazzo di livello
è questo siamo sott'acqua raga io direi
che per oggi posso concludere qui sei
video è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
in ogni video trovate nella descrizione
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci vediamo un prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]
e cazzo era sporca